>>> WHAT'S AMAZING IN RETROSPECT
IS THAT TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THIS
STORY FIRST BROKE, THE USUAL
LIARS AND POWER WORSHIPERS IN
THE MEDIA, THOSE OF WHOM THE
RARE FEW EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
TONY BOBULINSKI EXISTED,
DISMISSED THE STORY BY SAYING,
YEAH, BUT IT'S BIDEN'S SON AND
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH BIDEN.
AS IF HUNTER BIDEN WOULD BE ABLE
TO MAKE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SAY UKRAINE OR CHINA ON THE
BASIS OF HIS OWN EXPERTISE WHICH
AMOUNTED TO PRECISELY NOTHING.
HE NEVER HAD A REAL JOB.
HE HAD NO SKILLS.
HOW DID HE GET SO RICH?
BECAUSE HIS DAD WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE SELLING ACCESS TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE MONEY WAS IN PART GOING TO
JOE BIDEN.
THAT WAS CLEAR BECAUSE HUNTER
BIDEN SAID IT REPEATEDLY ON
TEXTS THAT ANY NEWS ORGANIZATION
COULD HAVE RED.
TONY BOBULINSKI KNEW THAT
BECAUSE HE SAW THAT.
HE HAD ALREADY MET WITH JOE
BIDEN DIRECTLY.
WE ASKED HIM AGAIN ABOUT THIS.
PUT SOME FLESH ON THOSE BONES,
AND HE DID.
WATCH.
>> YOUR BUSINESS PARTNERS WITH
HUNTER AND JIM BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN'S SON AND BROTHER.
>> CORRECT.
>> HUNTER BIDEN HAS RECEIVED
SOME COVERAGE FOR HIS ARTS.
>> I CALL IT THE BIDEN FAMILY.
AS YOU KNOW, I SAY IT'S BEEN
WELL DOCUMENTED.
YU WELL DOCUMENTED IT.
I MET WITH JOE MULTIPLE TIMES.
NOW SUBSEQUENT TO THE ELECTION
HE IS NOW THE SITTING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF DATA
POINTS THAT JOE BIDEN WAS ACTING
IN A CAPITALISTIC TERM, I WOULD
SAY THE CHAIRMAN.
THE CHAIRMAN OF JPMORGAN DOESN'T
TAKE EIGHT MEETINGS DOWN WITH
PEOPLE ANALYZING COMPANIES.
THE CHAIRMAN SERVES A PURPOSE.
HE'S A FIGUREHEAD.
HE SHOWS UP AS MEETINGS AND
SHAKES HANDS AND ADVISES.
HE HAS FAITH AND HIS TEAM.
EFFECTIVELY, THAT WAS JOE
BIDEN'S ROLE IN THE BIDEN FAMILY
BUSINESS VENTURES AROUND THE
WORLD.
NOT JUST MY VENTURE.
I MET WITH HIM MULTIPLE TIMES.
I THINK IT WAS THE DAILY MAIL
THAT MADE A RECORDING PUBLIC
WHERE JOE BIDEN REACHES OUT TO
HUNTER BIDEN IN DECEMBER 2018
AFTER THE NEW YORK TIMES HAD
PUBLISHED AN EXTENSIVE ARTICLE
ON CFC CHAIRMAN E AND HOW THEY
WERE DEPLOYING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AROUND THE WORLD WOULD
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENTS BASICALLY
ACTING AS THE ARM.
>> I'D LIKE TO PLAY THAT
VOICEMAIL FROM THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM JOE BIDEN TO HIS SON
HUNTER.
>> HEY PAL, IT'S DAD.
IT'S 8:15 ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
GIVE ME A CALL.
NOTHING URGENT.
I JUST WANT TO TALK TO.
I SAW THE ARTICLE ONLINE THAT'S
GOING TO BE PRINTED TOMORROW.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR.
ANYWAY, IF YOU GET A CHANCE,
GIVE ME A CALL.
I LOVE YOU.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> IT'S STAGGERING.
THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT IS JOE BIDEN IN HIS OWN
VOICE TELLING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE I WAS ALWAYS WELL AWARE
OF THE BUSINESS VENTURES MY
FAMILY WAS INVOLVED IN.
SO MUCH SO I COULD TELL MY SON I
READ A DETAILED ARTICLE THAT HAS
50 FACTS IN IT.
IMAGINE JUST SITTING IN A ROOM
WITH NATIONAL SECURITY AND THAT
INTEL AGENCIES WITH THAT ARTICLE
TALKING ABOUT CORRUPTION,
TALKING ABOUT CHINA, TALKING
ABOUT THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY, THE LIBERATION PARTY OF
CHINA.
JOE BIDEN IS SAYING I READ THAT
ARTICLE AND YOU ARE IN THE
CLEAR, HUNTER.
HE LEAVES THAT VOICEMAIL FOR HIS
SON.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THE BIDENS
WERE AWARE OF THE EFFECTS ON THE
UNITED STATES OF DOING BUSINESS
WITH CHINA?
>> IT'S FUNNY.
I THINK IN THEIR MIND THEY FEW
RUSSIA AS A BIGGER THREAT THAN
CHINA.
THEY SORT OF TALK AND OPERATE
LIKE THAT.
THAT WAS ALWAYS SURPRISING TO
ME.
BUT I THINK THEY ARE WELL AWARE
OF IT.
THE MAGNITUDE OF HUNTER AND HIS
OWN WORDS TALKS ABOUT BEING IN
BUSINESS WITH THE SPY CHIEF OF
CHINA.
>> DID YOU EVER TALK TO HUNTER
BIDEN DIRECTLY ABOUT THIS?
>> OBVIOUSLY I WAS AWARE OF WHAT
WAS BEING DONE IN 2015 AND 2016
BY JAMES GILLIAR AND ROB WALKER
AND THE CHINESE COMPANY CFC
WHILE JOE BIDEN WAS THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THERE WAS A TEXT MESSAGE WHERE
EARLY ON I HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
HUNTER ABOUT WHAT IS CFC FOCUSED
ON AND CHAIRMAN YE.
ARE THEY DOING ANY DEAL?
WHAT KIND OF DEALS?
HUNTER IN A LONG TEXT MESSAGE
SAYS WE ARE WILLING TO DO ANY
DEALS EXCEPT I THINK HE EXCLUDED
MILITARY TECH THAT WOULD GIVE
THE CHINESE MILITARY AN
ADVANTAGE OVER THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY.
BUT OUTSIDE OF THAT THEY WERE
READY AND WILLING TO DO ANY
OTHER DEAL.
>> YOU SAID THEY VIEWED RUSSIA
AND IT'S CLEARLY TRUE THAT THEY
DO THAT IT'S A BIGGER THREAT
THAN CHINA.
THAT IS LUDICROUS.
BUT THEY WERE ALSO WILLING TO DO
BUSINESS WITH RUSSIA, CORRECT?
>> THEY WERE.
THERE IS A VERY WELL DOCUMENTED
SENATOR JOHNSON AND SENATOR
GRASSLEY.
SADLY ENOUGH IT CAME OUT AFTER
THE ELECTION.
THEY INITIALLY PUBLISHED A
REPORT IN SEPTEMBER 2022 WEEKS
AFTER THE ELECTION IN NOVEMBER
2028 THEY PUBLISHED A 70 PAGE
DOCUMENT THAT IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY WATCHING
THIS THAT WANTS TO REVIEW IT.
IT GOES THROUGH IN DETAIL THE
INVOLVEMENT OF HUNTER BIDEN AND
THE BIDEN FAMILY WITH KNOWLEDGE
OF A DEAL THAT WAS BEING STRUCK
BETWEEN CFC BUYING A $9 BILLION
STAKE IN THE U.S. SANCTION
RUSSIA CONTROLLED BY PRUDENT
ENERGY COMPANY AND RIDING A
$9 BILLION CHECK.
THEY WEREN'T A SILENT PARTNER
AND PUTTING $9 MILLION OR
$90 MILLION OR $900 MILLION.
THEY WERE BUYING A $9 BILLION
STAKE APPROXIMATELY 14%.
ONCE AGAIN, U.S. SANCTION TO.
BOUDIN -CONTROLLED RUSSIAN
ENERGY COMPANY.
HUNTER BIDEN AND THE BIDEN
FAMILY WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL
OF THAT.
>> HAVE YOU HAD ANY CONTACT WITH
HUNTER OR JIM BIDEN CORRECT?
>> THE LAST CONTACT I HAD WITH
THE BIDEN FAMILY WAS IN MY
INTERVIEW WITH THE FBI ON
OCTOBER 23 FOR THE FIVE PLUS
HOURS.
ON MY BLACKBERRY JIM BIDEN
CALLED ME VIA WHAT'S APP.
I WAS THERE VOLUNTARILY, SO MY
PHONE STARTS RINGING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE INTERVIEW.
I LOOKED DOWN AND I SAID IS HE
REALLY CALLING ME WRITE NOW?
I SHOW THE PHONE TO MY LAWYER
AND THEN I SHOW IT TO THE
AGENTS.
THE AGENTS GOT UP AND LEFT THE
ROOM.
THEY SAID YOU CAN TAKE THE CALL
IF YOU WANT.
I ANSWERED IT.
THERE WAS NOBODY ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS A MISTAKE
OR THEY WERE TRYING TO SEND ME A
MESSAGE OR WHAT IT WAS.
THAT'S THE LAST INTERACTION OR
COMMUNICATION I HAD WITH THE
BIDEN FAMILY.
>> YOU ARE THE KEY TO THIS
STORY.
THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE.
>> I WISH I WASN'T.
>> OF COURSE.
YOU DIDN'T CHOOSE IT, OBVIOUSLY,
BUT YOU ARE.
THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT AT STAKE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES MIGHT BE FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
MY IMMEDIATE FAMILY, MY EXTENDED
FAMILY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THEY ARE ALL
PATRIOTS.
WE WE BLEED RED, WHITE AND BLUE.
WE BELIEVE IN THIS GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE ENTIRE WORLD
HANDS DOWN.
THESE FACTS MATTER.
I DON'T MATTER.
THE FACTS MATTER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
KNOW THEM.
AND VERIFY THEM.
AS FOR SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN
TO VERIFY THEM.
ULTIMATELY HOLD THE BIDEN FAMILY
IN THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEM.
TO THIS DAY, TWO YEARS JOE BIDEN
HAS YET TO BE ASKED DID HE EVER
MEET WITH ME?
>> NOT ONE TIME?
>> NOT ONE TIME.
>> WE HAVE HAD TWO YEARS TO LOOK
INTO YOU.
WE LOOKED INTO YOU BEFORE OUR
FIRST INTERVIEW.
OUR VIEWERS SHOULD KNOW WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF WHISTLEBLOWERS.
I HAVE OVER 30 YEARS.
A LOT OF THEM ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH.
PROBABLY MOST.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM WANT
SOMETHING.
WE CAN SAY BECAUSE WE VERIFY
THAT YOU ARE NOT LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING.
YOU DON'T NEED THE MONEY, THAT'S
FOR SURE.
THE ONLY DOWNSIDE FOR YOU IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WE WERE CONFIDENT
ENOUGH TO DO A SECOND INTERVIEW.
WHY ARE YOU COMING OUT NOW
AGAIN?
>> I AM COMING OUT NOW BECAUSE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE STILL
BEING LIED TO ABOUT THE FACTS.
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE.
THEY ARE STILL THINKING THAT
DEAL NEVER HAPPENED HER HUNTER
BIDEN WAS A TROUBLED CHILD.
THEY ARE NOT AWARE OF THE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTATION AND THE FACTS.
THE DOJ IS CLAIMING THEY HAD TO
COUCH THIS AND THEY CANNOT DO
ANYTHING DURING THE ELECTION.
I DON'T WANT TO SIT HERE IN
DECEMBER AND THEY INDICT HUNTER
BIDEN AND THEN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHY WEREN'T WE
MADE AWARE OF THE FACTS?
THIS IS CRAZY.
I WOULD HAVE CHANGED MY VOTE FOR
THAT CONGRESSMAN OR SENATOR OR
GOVERNOR OR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT IS WHY I AM COMING OUT NOW.
AS I REFERENCED EARLIER I CAME
BACK FROM SUMMER TRAVEL TO FIND
OUT THAT THE PERSON THAT WAS
RUNNING POINT ON THE TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS AND TEXT MESSAGES THAT
WERE PROVIDED TO THE FBI JUST
SUDDENLY RETIRED AND WALKED OUT
OF THE BUILDING.
>> YOU HAVE GOT THE MOST
POWERFUL AGENCIES IN THE WORLD,
THE FBI AND CIA, WORKING AGAINST
YOU.
THAT'S NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN IT HAPPEN.
>> YOU JUST MADE MY HEART
SKIPPED.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
THAT'S QUITE AN ARRAY OF
OPPONENTS.
>> RED, WHITE AND BLUE.
GREATEST COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH.
I BELIEVE FACTS MATTER AND THE
TRUTH ULTIMATELY WILL COME OUT.
>> DID YOU HEAR THAT?
HE SAID THAT JOE BIDEN'S BROTHER
CALLED HIM WHILE HE WAS TALKING
TO THE FBI.
HOW WOULD JOE BIDEN'S BROTHER
KNOW HE WAS TALKING TO THE FBI?
WHO IS RUNNING THE FBI?
HIS NAME IS CHRIS WRAY.
WE KNOW THAT THE FBI SUPPRESS
THE STORY.
THEY NEVER CALLED BOBULINSKI
BACK AND NEVER DID A SECOND
INTERVIEW.
THEN THEY CALLED THE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES TO CENSOR IT TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
DOES THAT EV